dieses Gericht kommt direkt aus dem
Reiskocher die Küche bleibt also sauber
m butterzartes Hähnchen würziger Reis
was will man mehr und das beste ist das
hier ist nur ein Grundrezept wir
beginnen mit maisishähnchen dazu gebe
ich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
Kurkuma Sesamöl dunkle Sojasoße und
Austernsoße Gewürze sind euch überlassen
und das Massieren wir jetzt gut ein
entweder ordentlich einmassieren oder
marinieren lassen jetzt noch ein
bisschen frisch geriebener Knoblauch
dazu und fertig Knoblauch darf nicht
fehlen mein Reis habe ich gewaschen und
gebe ihn einfach in den Reiskocher
hinein dazu gebe ich jetzt Hühner brüen
zack etwas Sesamöl und ein paar
ingwerstifte es folgt unser mariniertes
Hähnchen einfach oben drauf und auch
wenn man sich jetzt schlecht vorstellen
kann ist das alles was wir machen müssen
Standardmodus einschalten und
deckeldruck einfach warten wenn der
Reiskocher anzeigt dass es fast fertig
ist machen wir noch mal auf und geben
einfach ein paar frische
Frühlingszwiebeln oder Gemüse unserer
Wahl noch mit dazu wenn wir es direkt am
Anfang mitgeben dann wird es einfach zu
weich unser chicken ist perfekt gegart
die Frühlingszwiebeln haben noch ein
bisschen Biss und das riete ich mir
jetzt einmal schön
an